all right hundreds of thousands of
federal employees who are without pay
are beginning to feel the impact
collectively they're losing more than
1.4 billion dollars a week Adriana Diaz
spoke to one of more than 13,000 EPA
workers who are wondering how to pay
their bills and she's outside the APA
office in Lenexa Kansas just southwest
of Kansas City
Adriana good morning good morning the
nearly 500 employees who work at this
EPA office don't know when they're not
getting paid one woman told us she has
$300 in the bank
her family can't survive on her
husband's salary alone and they won't be
able to make their February bills she
wanted to be clear that she spoke to us
as a private citizen and local union
president it's my job it's my livelihood
it's how I put food on the table for my
children when Sara Watterson left work
on New Year's Eve
she still had a job but no sense of
security so you have to go to your
landlord and say I don't know how I'm
gonna pay you I've never had to do that
the former Marine now works as an office
manager for the EPA in Kansas how does
it feel for someone who has a full-time
job works for the federal government to
have to go to their landlord and ask for
I don't even know what to call it mercy
the mother of two is the family's
primary breadwinner she received her
last paycheck at the end of December
have you started thinking about where
you might save if this shutdown goes
longer we're trying to cut the grocery
bills just down to the necessities I
mean we don't live extravagantly so it's
hard to cut out any bills do your kids
sense that something's going on
absolutely they want to know why there
aren't certain foods in the house they
want to know why we can't go out to eat
to try to help the government provided
sample letters last month that federal
employees can show creditors explaining
why they're struggling to pay their
bills according to the real estate
website Zillow unpaid federal workers
will oh four hundred and thirty-eight
million dollars this month in mortgage
and rent payments do you think it's
worth keeping the government shutdown
going on in order to potentially get
funding for the border wall I don't know
that it's worth the livelihoods of
people I don't know that anything would
be worth that the shutdown is affecting
agencies across the country but the
three hardest hit are Homeland Security
the Department of Justice and the
Department of Agriculture some employees
here at this EPA office say that if
their projects are put on hold for too
long it could endanger the public Gail
okay these are real people we're talking
about thank you very much Adriana